I had to ask you truth or dare
are you aware that olivia is in love
with your boyfriend she's mine we stop
Penelope damn
Miguel Olivia let's get this party
started type garnet truth what are your
intentions with our suite Olivia I
needed to find someone with friends that
I could trick into coming here
I could tell Olivia was an easy target I
brought you all up here cuz I'm okay
with strangers dying if it means I get
to live what the hell the game is real
okay wherever you go whatever you do
it'll find you okay yeah something
really weird has been going on ever
since Mexico oh come on
serious I'm seeing things truth all
right there dear I know it sounds insane
just something this fine young lady here
dared me to show you my business Carter
said tell the truth or you die do the
dare or you die refused to play you
don't screw this man you die
we're not playing the game it's playing
us so what do we do only choose truth
wait I'm sorry touch me again and I'll
break that hand truth that's not how
this works only game decides honey break
Olivia's hand you have to do it look as
pissed as I am at you right now there's
no way I'm gonna break your hand you
don't really have a choice
God just do it this game is too smart
half the people in this photo are now
dead you need to find the left start at
all this
how do we get out of this game alive
you can't it only ends with all the
players are dead baby returns next dare
me to choose you look for one of you to
kill truth or dare
you